hey guys today we're gonna talk about
how to look at least 10 years younger
okay so I'm 54 years old going on 29 and
my wife is 55 and I'm gonna tell you our
secret but if I tell you this you have
to promise not to tell anyone okay
you're gonna have to sign off on the
comment below and say you won't tell
anyone this is just between you and me
in the four walls and I'm just being
totally kidding around because this is
really it's not really a secret it's
just very basic common sense because if
you think about it if you want really
useful skin
what does skin man have fat in protein
okay is it made out of unsaturated fats
no it's made out of saturated fats so
take a wild guess what you should be
eating more of that's right
cholesterol and saturated fats the exact
things that they tell you not to eat I
mean think about if you go in a low-fat
diet you start getting old really fast
so if you want aging skin just starve
yourself of fats okay especially
saturated fats all right now what does
cholesterol and saturated fats do for
you well there's three things 50% of
your cell membranes are made out of
cholesterol okay because we meet
cholesterol body makes it and we need it
from our diet it also helps you make
bile to help you digest the fat that
you're eating especially to extract the
fat soluble vitamins out of that fat
also the cholesterol is needed to make
hormones because as you know as you get
older you lose your hormones you look
older right so we want to make sure the
food the precursors the raw material for
your hormones are there very very
important now under ball the fats and
vitamins the vitamin A is the most
important anti-aging fat soluble vitamin
for your skin okay the epidermis and the
dermis the different layers of the skin
are controlled by vitamin a and if you
have enough vitamin A your skin will be
soft and firm and it won't be so dry
because vitamin A deficiency
it creates dry skin scaly skin it's
called actually corn avocation which is
real
rough skin you get acne I don't know if
you knew this but the genes that make
collagen need vitamin A so vitamin A
triggers the production of collagen now
where do you get vitamin A well you can
get it from leafy greens right but the
beta carotene in the leafy greens
including kale and spinach and other
greens is a precursor it's not that
retinal the active form of vitamin A it
has to be converted into the active form
so it's important to consume these
things the exact oxidants these
phytonutrients but if you're doing high
amounts of beta-carotene without enough
of these active forms your skin is not
going to look as youthful you really
need the active form of vitamin A so
guess where you get vitamin A egg yolks
okay cod liver oil butter salmon fish
goats cheese make sure that the color
all you get is virgin cod liver oil it's
just a higher quality make sure the eggs
that you consume are pasture raised
organic very important the next
important vitamin would be vitamin E ok
vitamin E protects the skin against
aging against sunburns against oxidizing
ok it will prevent wrinkles too it
actually is anti scarring and it
supports your pituitary hormones ok so
it's another key nutrient to help as a
building block especially if you're
going through menopause as you get older
your ovaries go in hibernation they go
in retirement they don't work anymore
so that means you don't need as many sex
hormones so the pituitary doesn't output
as many hormones and the vitamin E
starts dropping down you need vitamin E
for those sex hormones so it's very very
important to have vitamin E where do you
give at a mini well you get it from palm
oil eco-friendly of course especially
the red palm oil leafy greens you can
get it from wheat germ oil I don't like
that source but you can olive oil seeds
and nuts and a lot of the other foods
that I mentioned about vitamin A
also have vitamin E now the other thing
on the flipside that you need to focus
on is what to avoid okay the number one
thing to avoid to prevent aging skin is
AGEs just so happens that stands for
age this stands for advanced glycation
end-products now what is that basically
when you combine protein and sugar or
protein with fat like in a deep-fried
doughnut or french fries or if you're
taking protein like barbecued ribs and
you're actually compiling all that sugar
with the protein you create these sticky
proteins and the protein starts getting
sticky and it starts clogging everything
up in the eye and the artery and your
glands but it's gonna make your skin
look very very old very very fast
smoking is gonna age the skin and of
course smoking actually causes these
advanced glycation end-products as well
stress we want to avoid cortisol
cortisol in high amounts ages the skin
so definitely avoid these things right
here and of course sugar avoid sugar and
refined carbohydrates simply because
that's going to oxidize and aged things
very very fast so this is just one more
reason that the healthy ketogenic diet
is important if we also add intermittent
fasting to this we can accelerate it
even more because we get repair actions
and when you're doing intamin fast and
you go through autophagy which kind of
cleans out these damaged proteins that
are unusable now so you can clean up the
old stuff within intermittent fasting and
with healthy keto add enough saturated
fats to provide these nutrients and
other nutrients to start looking younger
so thanks for watching and I will see
you in the next video hey guys real
quick I have a new healthy keto eating
plan for you just go to DRBERG.com
it's right on the front page I put a
link down below download it it's free
check it out